l'apb ils en ont tous entendu parler ces
élèves de terminale au lycée jean vilar
de plaisir ont déjà commencé à explorer
le site internet ouvert du 20 janvier au
20 mars
c'est l'étape incontournable pour
choisir sa future filière et faire ses
voeux mais tous ne la présentent pas de
la même manière
ça nous rassure un petit peu le fait
d'avoir un support de pouvoir
hiérarchisé
bon c'est vrai qu'il ya des contraintes
de temps ça peut nous servir de
plateforme pour envoyer nos dossiers au
lieu d'avoir à les envoyer par courrier
si on n'a pas fait de recherche avance
on n'a pas était sur les sites des
universités
ça peut être compliqué dans cet
établissement les élèves sont
sensibilisés à la procédure dès la
classe de première
mais naviguer sur le portail n'est pas
la partie la plus compliquée abb site
une procédure technique
ce que je veux dire par là ça n'est pas
le noeud de l'orientation apb et me dit
comment faire mais ne me dit pas quoi
faire pour faciliter le choix des futurs
bacheliers les admissions postbac
évoluer cette année les voeux ont été
simplifiées et sont passés de 36 à 24
dès à présent la filière est prioritaire
sur l'établissement pour qu'aucun élève
on se retrouve sans formation les grands
changements sont
on oblige les élèves à formuler certains
veut pour optimiser
l'admission
en licence puisqu'il ya des filières qui
sont en tension est donc
permettre à chaque élève retrouver une
place à l'université pour ceux qui
aspirent à rentrer en classe
préparatoire école de commerce ou autres
filières en alternance les démarches
sont là un peu plus compliqué il faut
commencer à s'y intéresser
bien avant le processus d'admission post
baccalauréat après vous avez aussi
toutes les filières où il ya des des
concours d'entrée les écoles
d'ingénieurs les écoles de commerce
donc là il faut effectivement avoir
réfléchi avant voire vers quel concours
on se dirige ce concours donne accès à
quelle école
voilà toute cette démarche là se fait
pas forcément en une fois en un mois ça
peut prendre du temps
aucune raison de s'alarmer il n'est pas
encore trop tard mais trois dates clés
sont à garder en tête les élèves ont
jusqu'au 20 mars pour formuler leur
choix jusqu'au 31 mai pour les classes
et les décisions finales pour les voeux
seront rendus le 24 juin